the family of a climber who died in
Oregon's highest mountain says a delay
in dispatching a rescue helicopter led
to his death John Jenkins was near the
summit of Mount Hood last May when he
fell about 600 feet the chopper arrived
nearly five hours later bianna golodryga
shows us emergency calls that his family
claims went unheeded beyond a good
morning good morning and as you'll hear
there were several emergency calls John
Jenkins family filed a 10 million dollar
wrongful death lawsuit this week against
the Sheriff's Department and 911 call
center in Oregon they believe if those
calls were handled properly Jenkins
might still be alive
the first call to 911 approximately
10:40 a.m. John Jenkins nearly two miles
up Mount Hood had just tumbled 600 feet
down its slope and survived the bus
without cable I don't know if anything's
broken we weren't sure how bad the
situation was another climber Jessie
Cornett made that 911 dispatcher
transferred him to a Clackamas County
deputy who told him to call the Ski
Patrol at a nearby resort because 911
was unwilling to help I'm suddenly
googling to find out a number to call
ski patrol volunteers arrived to help
more than half an hour later someone
made a second 911 response for a fallen
climber
they said they'd call back if needed the
Sheriff's Department was called again at
1211 p.m. this time for a helicopter it
arrived at 3:11 p.m. about four and a
half hours after Jenkins fell is at this
point just obviously in pain wailing
saying that he can't breathe we were
part of something good until we realized
that a key link had fail this a lawsuit
filed by Jenkins family says his
breathing and pulse stopped as he was
lifted into the chopper they accused the
county the Sheriff's Department and the
911 center of not requesting the
helicopter in time
and routing 911 callers to an improperly
trained officer it's a very very
stressful job it's a very thankless job
Rob McMullen is president of Nena and
organization of 911s
he says dispatchers rarely get
recognized for the good work they do a
lot of times the only work of that you
see of dispatchers is the negativity
that happens on a call and that gets
broadcast over the media a County
spokesman says climbing Mount Hood can
be deadly and that its employees
responded appropriately
he told CBS this morning the county is
very proud of the fine work of the women
and men who are involved in rescue
efforts they risk their lives to save
the lives of others and no doubt they do
but the family and of course even Jesse
Cornett the climber who found him so
that he was in stable condition
initially that he was talking about Oh
tomorrow's gonna be bad for me I'm gonna
be all roughed up and then things
deteriorated quickly well that's what's
so tragic is in Jenkins his girlfriend
was there and there were those other
climbers and at first he seemed
amazingly to be you know hurt but not
and and then to have it go precious yeah
absolutely do you think even to be a lot
of questions to be answered there that's
right oh very tough story thank you be
honest